have you ever listened to Common  probably when pops or somebody was  listening Chicago Legend twister too  yeah yeah twister for sure I went to the  gun range with twister and [ __ ] twisted  took you to the gun range yeah Twisted  took me to the guy range me and a lot of  my homies we were shooting guns and [ __ ]  he was showing us all the exclusive ass  guns he got and [ __ ] all type of bit  crazy ass [ __ ] he's like training people  like how to get their gun permit and  yeah that's what that's that's what he  gonna do with me that's fine shout out  to twister Twister's a great guy how did  he just reach out to you how did that  end up happening um I think we supposed  to have been doing the song or some [ __ ]  and then you know he was just on some  regular [ __ ] like it's beyond the song  type [ __ ] like let's just build you know  on some big brother bro [ __ ] you know  he's a good dude yeah for sure shout out  to say he's a [ __ ] Legend shout out  to Chicago man